so I got a question for you what are the
difference is for a kid to be raised in
a welfare class a working class and a
professional class family we're going to
talk about that here today I'll Patrick
give you host a value team and weekly
and we are right now at Montrose
Community Park here I believe close to
La Crescenta area where we used to play
basketball here all the time from
morning til night we just be trying to
hit a home run on this side and God
knows how many home runs we hit on that
side we just had a great time playing
baseball here growing up but today's
message today's message so three
different environments the kid grows up
in and and what this author from the
book the genius and all of us wants to
explain is he talks about a formula G
times e equals the rate of success a
person could have so G represents the
genius in all of us you see everybody
inside of them has a genius in among
fortunately very few of us ever find out
about that genius because of E and we're
going to talk about it today so some of
the numbers si did when they did the
studies on these families in Kansas in
the 1980s was very simple between those
three different families welfare working
and professional class and here's what
they came up with a kid being race and a
professional class heard 1500 more words
per hour then in work welfare class kid
so 1500 more words per hour to be around
than a welfare kid whether it's
listening to recordings listening to mom
and dad talk business talk CPA France
whatever it is it's 1500 more Wars they
were exposed to and complex words then
the welfare class which one they're
going to do to math it's roughly eight
million more words per year and it's
roughly 32 million words over a
four-year period so imagine a kid being
raised in a professional class family
that has gone 32 million words by the
time it's four years old imagine what
his brain is doing the muscle in his
brain and how his genius is figuring
everything out versus a welfare class as
hasn't done that yet right
so the next thing it talks about stats
is how many encouraging and discouraging
words each class gives their kids and
this is what the numbers look like
the professional class family encourages
their kids 560,000 times more than they
discourage them by the time they turn 18
years old five hundred and sixty
thousand more times encouragement than
discouragement the working class was one
hundred thousand encouraging and a
welfare class was one hundred thousand
more discouraging words than encouraging
words so you can see what the
differences between welfare the working
class and a professional class and I
posed the question to you what kind of
an environment were you raised in you
know odds are you're probably in the
welfare or the working class and if you
are in the professional class now the
question becomes the debate where well I
have this genius a lot of people don't
think they're talented they're gifted a
lot of people don't think I don't
understand how special they are and how
capable they are and they have all these
fears insecurities anxieties because
somebody said you're too slow you're not
smart enough you're not this you're not
smart you can't make it you don't have a
degree you grew up in a family you grew
up in a poor family you know our family
doesn't make it nobody my family does
this your loser all of these things have
residual effects until you give the
complete opposite battle to it you will
forever believe that now it is going to
be a struggle it's not gonna be an
overnight quick fix it's not going to be
that however the question becomes you
know what do I need to do in order for
me if I was raised in a working-class or
welfare cut do I really have a shot at
going and achieving something big and
understanding my genius that I have in
me absolutely but it's gonna take some
work and here's what the work is so now
you need to be responsible and feeding
yourself 1500 plus words per hour over
the next four year period and this is
not a 90 day quiz or a 20 day exercise
so you need to have recordings in your
car biographies you're listening to
self-help books business books finance
book anything that's feeding your mind
history books political books stuff
that's just feeding your mind they call
that chunking chunking is a lot of
information put in at the same time they
do this at some schools and universities
to get kids brain vibrating as a
high level because the information that
they're being fed so you need to do to
1500 words the other part is you need to
be having affirmations on a daily basis
because you haven't had people
encouraging your life and it's been a
lot of criticism you need to on a daily
basis constantly encourage yourself
constantly build yourself up constantly
tell yourself how special constant is
that we can do it better you can do it
faster and be around an environment of
people that are challenging you
encouraging you and believing in the
fact that you can also do it on last but
not least my goodness reading books is
probably one of the best weapons you
could use to completely change the way
you think about yourself for all the
criticism you have gone through as a kid
now more feeding more information more
affirmation the quicker your recreating
the more you're starting to realize I
can do something big I have something
special to myself the belief goes higher
with the environment than the rest is
history you do what you want to do in
life because you figured out the formula
for you to achieve success in your life
however don't be the person that's
listening to this insane no wonder I
don't have success in life because the
environment I was raised in no wonder
it's my mom's was my dad's was my
brothers were it's nobody's fault no
one's perfect this was the life that was
given to you because God believes you
can do something with this light now
it's on you to go out there and make
something out of it
it's my message of the week to you and I
wish you were here with us to play a lot
of baseball seeing how your swing is but
please be sure to subscribe to this
channel and comment on the bottom
[Music]